-President Trump declared
a national emergency on Friday,
and then spent
the rest of the weekend
lashing out at critics.
For more on this,
it's time for
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
After Trump unilaterally
bypassed Congress
by declaring
a fake national emergency
to build his border wall,
he spent the rest of the weekend
calling the media
the enemy of the people,
demanded retribution
against TV networks,
and called
Justice Department officials
who investigated him treasonous.
It's more obvious every day
that Trump's natural inclination
is to be a dictator.
He could even try to grow
a dictator mustache,
but based on the rest
of his hair situation,
I'm not sure.
[ Laughter ]
And Trump would be even scarier
if he weren't
so easily distracted.
For example, he couldn't
even make it 24 hours
after declaring
his national emergency
before he escaped to Florida
for a weekend of golf
and lounging around at
his private club in Palm Beach,
where he was spotted on Saturday
waiting for breakfast.
-President Trump
spending his first day
following
that emergency declaration
at the Trump International
Golf Club down in Palm Beach,
and this photo
of President Trump
at the club's omelette bar
went viral,
getting retweeted
thousands of times over.
-There's no clearer sign
this is not a real emergency
than the fact that
he is at an omelette bar.
In real emergency,
no one goes to the omelette bar.
"The building is on fire!"
[ As Donald Trump ] "I'll be
right there! Oh, yeah!
Onions, green peppers, ham --
Do you have ham?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Put it in a to-go box!"
[ Normal voice ] Also, it's good
to see your emergency wear is
the official uniform
of golf grandpas everywhere.
Look at him.
He looks like
a 6-foot-tall Band-Aid.
[ Laughter ]
I'm shocked that he wasn't
wearing a fanny pack
and trying to get them
to take an expired coupon.
I'm sorry, but that is not how
a president should look ever,
but especially
during an emergency.
When President Obama
got Bin Laden,
he was in the situation room
surrounded by generals.
Can you imagine Trump
overseeing that mission
from the omelette bar
at his golf club?
[ As Donald Trump ] Navy SEALs,
this is your president.
Give me full situ-- Wait.
Hold on. What's that?
Yeah, yeah, hash browns."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] And even when
he's not in Florida golfing
and eating soft foods,
it's clear we've elected
as our president
an adult grandpa who has trouble
forming coherent sentences.
For example, during his
press conference on Friday,
Trump explained that he expected
a protracted court challenge
to his national emergency
declaration,
although it was less
of an explanation
and more of a sing-song ramble.
-I'll sign the final papers
as soon as I get
into the Oval Office.
And we will have
a national emergency.
And we will then be sued.
And they will sue us
in the ninth circuit,
even though
it shouldn't be there.
And we will possibly
get a bad ruling.
And then we'll get
another bad ruling.
And then we'll end up
in the Supreme Court.
And, hopefully,
we'll get a fair shake.
And we'll win
in the Supreme Court,
just like the ban.
They sued us
in the ninth circuit,
and we lost.
And then we lost
in the appellate division.
And there we went
to the Supreme Court,
and we won.
-he sounds like a 5-year-old
telling you
what he saw at the zoo.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ As Donald Trump ]
"And then we saw the monkeys,
and they were eating bananas,
and Todd said,
'We used to be apes,'
and I said that's not true,
and Todd said, 'Yes, it is!',
and then a bird
crapped on his head.
[ Normal voice ] Of course,
it's true that Trump's
national emergency declaration
will be challenged in court,
given that it's very likely
unconstitutional.
If Trump has any chance
of winning in court, at all,
He has to insist that
this was his only choice,
that he had one thing,
one thing he had to say.
This is a real emergency.
We had to do it this way.
-I could do the wall
over a longer period of time.
I didn't need to do this.
But I'd rather do it
much faster.
-You didn't need to do this --
then it's not an emergency.
That's the exact opposite
of an emergency.
That's a choice.
That's like saying,
"I'm having emergency surgery
to get butt implants."
[ Laughter ]
"I didn't need to do this,
but I hate doing squats."
When he heard that,
even Rudy Giuliani said,
"Oh, no.
You shouldn't have said that."
[ Laughter ]
Trump might even know
on some level
that his national emergency
stands no chance
of surviving a court challenge,
and he very likely doesn't care,
because he's doing this entirely
to please a very narrow set
of right wing pundits
who hectored him
into building the wall,
like Rush Limbaugh,
who Trump actually namechecked
during his press conference
on Friday.
-Mr. President, could you
tell us to what degree
some of the outside
conservative voices
helped to shape your views
on this national emergency?
-I would talk about it.
Look, Sean Hannity has been
a terrific, terrific,
uh, supporter of what I do.
Not of me.
If I changed my views,
he wouldn't be with me.
Rush Limbaugh,
I think he's a great guy.
He can speak for three hours
without a phone call.
Try doing that sometime.
For three hours, he speaks.
He's got one of
the biggest audiences
in the history of the world.
I mean,
this guy is unbelievable.
Try speaking for three hours
without taking calls.
Taking calls is easy.
Okay, I'll answer this one,
I'll answer that one.
He goes for three hours,
and he's got an audience
that's fantastic.
-My God, that answer
took three hours.
[ Laughter ]
Also, if he's talking for three
hours without taking calls,
maybe nobody is calling him.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Rush Limbaugh ]
We're gonna open the phone line!
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
And even if you
put aside the chaos
this is causing here at home,
it definitely seems like
all of this is hurting our image
around the world, too.
Vice President Mike Pence
discovered that over the weekend
when he mentioned
President Trump
in his speech in Munich.
He clearly thought it was
gonna be an applause line
and it definitely was not.
-I bring greetings
from the 45th president
of the United States of America,
President Donald Trump.
[ Laughter ]
Last August...
-Say what you want
about Mike Pence,
the man knows how
to hold for silence.
[ Laughter ]
Never thought I would say this,
but Pence might have
to hire Jeb Bush
as his hype man.
-I bring greetings
from the 45th President
of the United States of America,
President Donald Trump.
-Please clap.
[ Laughter ]
-But a reaction like that...
[ Applause ]
A reaction like that must
really sting for Trump,
who craves validation
and praise.
In fact, over the weekend,
we learned that Trump asked
the prime minister of Japan
to nominate him
for a Nobel Prize.
A Japanese newspaper reported
that Japanese Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe nominated Trump
for the Nobel Peace Prize
last autumn
after receiving a request from
the U.S. government to do so,
which is especially
embarrassing,
given that on Friday,
Trump bragged about the fact
that Abe had nominated him
for the Nobel Prize
and claimed he had no idea
he was about to do that.
-Prime Minister Abe of Japan
gave me the most beautiful
copy of a letter
that he sent to the people
who give out a thing
called the Nobel Prize.
He said, "I have nominated you,
or respectfully,
on behalf of Japan,
I am asking them to give you
the Nobel Peace Prize."
I said, "Thank you."
-Oh, really?
You said thank you?
Did you also bribe him?
"Here you go, Shinzo.
This is for one free omelette.
[ Laughter ]
It is expired.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, maybe just frame it."
Somehow I doubt that Trump will
get that Nobel Peace Prize
after unilaterally declaring
a nonexistent emergency
at our border with Mexico.
For weeks,
Trump has gone back and forth
on the possibility
of declaring an emergency,
while also insisting he was
already building the wall,
as he did right before
the State of the Union address,
although he was
very coy about it.
-Are you saying now you expect
to declare a national --
-I don't want to say,
but you'll hear
the State of the Union,
and then you'll see
what happens right after
the State of the Union, okay?
-You'll hear
the State of the Union,
And then you'll see what happens
after the State of the Union.
Trump is so out of his depth,
he's dodging questions
by explaining how time works.
[ Laughter ]
"Mr. President,
didn't you say Mexico
would pay for the wall?
[ As Donald Trump ] I said
Mexico will pay for the wall
in the future,
not the present.
And everyone knows the future
comes after the present,
as opposed to the past,
which is before the present.
And we can't go
back to the past.
We can only go
back to the future,
which I learned
from that documentary
about Bernie Sanders.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
The reason...
The reason Trump
spent so many weeks
seesawing back and forth is
because Republicans
were reportedly
urging him not to declare
the national emergency,
knowing the move would be
unpopular and unconstitutional,
and yet as soon as Trump did it,
Republicans either supported him
or were muted
in their criticism,
like Iowa Senator
Chuck Grassley,
who only said, "I wish
he wouldn't have done it."
But Grassley was much angrier
when GOP Senate majority Leader
Mitch McConnell took
to the Senate floor last week
to announce that Trump would
declare a national emergency.
Grassley was talking about
something totally unrelated
and got mad when McConnell
interrupted him.
-Allowing these tax credits
incentives to lapse
has created uncertainty
for investors,
and the industry
about the availability
of these credits...
-Will the Senator yield?
-...jeopardizing
the long-term investments
necessary for the development
of these biofuels.
I hope the next time
I get a chance
to have the floor,
I won't be interrupted.
I yield the floor and put
the rest of my statement
in the record.
-Mr. President?
-Leader McConnell.
-You know you're old
when the young one
disrespecting you
is Mitch McConnell.
[ Laughter ]
That's how loud Grassley yells
when Trump cuts him in line
at the omelette bar.
[ Laughter ]
We're at the whims
of angry old men
screaming about stuff they hear
on talk radio
or see on Fox News.
Trump just rambles aimlessly
from one topic to the next,
and his alternate reality
is reinforced
by the right wing pundits,
who support him.
Trump is obviously
unfit to be president.
And if someone
beats him in 2020,
that person's going to get...
-A thing called the Nobel Prize.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]